dann gibt es aber auch die männer aus
dem umfeld von armin laschet die ganz
treu zu ihm halten aus nordrhein
westfalen zumindest der innenminister
herbert reul und auch sein
sozialminister sein gesundheitsminister
karl josef laumann der sich so geäußert
hat bei den kollegen vom wdr
die serie zu hoffen dass das was mit
laschet in den letzten wochen hat über
seine person medien dass sie müssen
nicht erstaunen vorstellen dass
hier eine sehr gute arbeit gemacht und
ich bin wirklich
beschäftigt
[Musik]
in diesem fall nicht um alles menschen
stattfindet und das ist bitter so muss
politische auseinandersetzung auch nicht
sein und die lässt doch einfach mal
sagen weil
das ist ja doch schon
vergeblich wie ich auch anwidert
wieder umgegangen wird also dass man die
angriffe vom politischen gegner krieg
das ist ja erst mal normal aber wie man
sie kriegt und dass sie dann auch
teilweise aus den eigenen reihen kommen
das ist schlicht und ergreifend ein
zustand der ist schlimm
ist das so reichelt wird hier ein
politiker vernichtet nein das ist
natürlich vollkommen unangebracht ist
vokabular dass der
nordrhein-westfälische
gesundheitsminister
dort findet aber es ist inzwischen so
etwas wie der typische dreiklang der
politik geworden unterstützen meucheln
im falle einer niederlage und dann
beklagen auf social media weil man für
solche videos so viele like sooo viel
zustimmung bekommen weil alle sagen er
hatte recht das ist menschlich so
schlimm es ist vollkommen klar in
welcher realität wenn ich
kanzlerkandidat werde weist jedoch in
welcher realität ich mich bewege das ist
eine brutale realität von machtpolitik
entweder ich gewinne dann bin ich der
könig oder nicht verliere dann werde ich
vom hof gejagt das ist politik das weiß
auch jeder und das jetzt sozusagen diese
selbst reinwaschung und übrigens leute
wie ich weiß jetzt nicht für herrn
laumann persönlich aber all die menschen
die jetzt den menschlichen umgang mit
amina schnitt beklagen und das erleben
wir als journalist immer wieder reden
hinter den kulissen komplett anders
sagen hinter den kulissen was für ein
verlierer es war es für ein looser ist
welche fehler gemacht hat und dann
stellen sich vor die kameras und
beklagen den menschlichen umgang den sie
selber betreiben den sie selber hinter
den kulissen betreiben hinter den
kulissen haben sie das messer und wenn
sie vor die kameras treten dann weil sie
tränen des bedauerns und des mitgefühls
das werden wir jetzt auch das haben wir
bei andrea nahles bei der spd schon
erlebt jetzt werden wir es in den
nächsten tagen bei armin laschet erleben
auch das muss ich sagen ist eine form
von wehleidigkeit die glaube ich wenn
ich deutschland das vier größte
industrieland der welt regieren will er
von den wählerinnen und wählern nicht
besonders geschätzt man muss einfach man
wenn man man kann nicht weinend vom
platz gehen auf dem level ja das geht
einfach nicht sondern man muss dann
tatsächlich auch in der niederlage
verantwortung übernehmen und da hat
social media tatsächlich schon vieles
verändert in den letzten jahren weil es
halt so gefeiert wird auf solche media
wenn ich dann solche rührseligen laumann
videos da fabriziere in denen so getan
wird als wäre armin laschet vollkommen
unschuldig einfach vernichtet worden
politisch vernichtet nein er hat selber
erst mal das stolze wahlergebnis der
stolzen volkspartei cdu im alleingang
vernichtet durch seine lacher in der
flut durch unvollkommen und
koordinierten wahlkampf armin laschet
das muss man ja leider sagen hat es
geschafft sich in für den gesamten
wahlkampf keinen einzigen satz mal
aufzuschreiben der irgendwie im
gedächtnis geblieben ist ja das ist die
fehleranalyse dies jetzt braucht wenn
die volkspartei cdu weiter eine
volkspartei bleiben will wenn man sich
statt fehleranalyse darauf konzentriert
armin laschet zu bemitleiden das mitleid
braucht auch gar nicht dafür ist der
taff genug dann wird das verheerenden
schaden beide cdu anrichten und auch bei
den wählerinnen und wählern ich frage
mich all die die gewählt haben und jetzt
erwarten dass eine lösung präsentiert
wird die wissen wollen wie es mit dem
land weitergeht und die jetzt ist es ja
gerade sehr anschaulich beschrieben
zeuge werden dieses machtpokers sehen
wir heute auch thematisieren was glaubst
du was löst als bei den menschen aus ich
glaube patricia das löst gar nichts mehr
bei den menschen aus weil das was armin
laschet damit noch einigen verbliebenen
getreuen veranstaltet findet ja
vollkommen losgelöst stadt von dem was
tatsächlich gerade an regierungsbildung
stattfindet es wird ja eine es wird ja
über eine regierung verhandelt es wird
zwischen erwachsenen die gute
wahlergebnis erzielt haben jetzt über
die zukunft einer deutschen
bundesregierung verhandelt und das was
armin laschet da gerade macht hat damit
eigentlich gar nichts mehr zu tun das
ist nur noch selbstbespiegelung und
realitätsverweigerung ich glaube das
finden viele menschen vermutlich
befremdlich was die lage und den zustand
der union angeht und
dass die realitätsverweigerung von armin
laschet aber ich glaube da muss man sich
keine sorge ums land machen denn es gibt
ja parteien die darüber verhandeln und
sich nicht bei 1 gucken lassen von von
dieser wehleidigkeit
[Musik]